[Music]
all right let's go to becca in whiteland
indiana what's up becca
hey
hey thank you so much for your time
i truly appreciate it thank you so much
i haven't got a good hey in a long time
it made my morning so what's up
okay um
i am struggling with i guess life not
turning out as i hoped it would um and
what i mean
i thought aren't we all um what i mean
by that is
i don't know if i want to say jealousy
but
my daughter
i think i feel like she basically has a
life that i want
and i know that sounds so wrong
i have a very good relationship with my
daughter okay um
and her but her boyfriend fiance he's
you know he's very attentive
um
he just asked if she needs help with me
he
wants to do things with her he wants to
be with her he's financially stable
and you know again i am so happy for her
and you know i feel like i do have a
blessed life but
it's just kind of like i feel like
you know oh because i recently um i've
been reading your book
and it's kind of like brought a lot of i
guess bricks out yeah and um and i
recently just like about a week ago just
i just kind of had a meltdown yeah and
my daughter was witness to it and
so it was just it was hard i mean it was
like kind of everything just came up
and she was there for me and
you know it's just it's a lot so so yeah
how old are you
i am 54. 54. and i've been married for
um almost 32 years oh so you're still
married
yeah yeah
so
these are hard
when you are
man
there's a lot here number one thank you
for being brave number two you're not
crazy okay you're not you're not nuts
all right
number three when you first start to
realize what you're carrying around
those bricks
i don't know somebody that has not had a
sit down and weep heavily i don't know
that person myself included when i
realized what i was carrying around it
was a lot
a i didn't realize i was even carrying
it b i didn't realize that those things
were still fresh so fresh to the to the
surface of my skin
three i didn't realize that i had
compromised so many of my other
relationships because of what i was
carrying right so all that stuff comes
at once and it's just a lot
um
yours is
yours is unique
in that
um
you're grieving something that you're
still living
well and i think a lot of it i know a
lot of it stems from
my past because i know i had
my childhood was pretty crappy
i mean it wasn't horrible but i mean it
was pretty crappy so i guess i had hoped
for better and
i just had hoped i guess that my
husband would honor me in the way that
her boyfriend seems to honor her
um for example she
you know we
she didn't want to have sex before
marriage and he has honored that and
i've even talked to her about it and
she's like no mom we haven't he's
you know you're peer pressuring her like
come on
she's like no no no no no i'm messing
with you i'm messing with you uh but but
he he he upholds her values right her
boundaries and probably vice versa yeah
so let me let me tell you two things
one is he's not perfect
he's an illusion
okay sure there's no such thing as mr
right that that that entity doesn't
exist outside of a marvel show okay yeah
and it's really tempting to look at your
life as it has been and the compromises
you've made the things that your husband
has steamrolled over whether those are
your needs your desires your dreams your
where you want to live all those things
right there's gonna be there's gonna be
a litany of them
it's easy to look at
your what your daughter has and say
well if i had had that
what i'll tell you is that's great that
he he listens to her values it means he
loves her and that's great
and that's great that she trusts him
with her boundaries that's great
um
but you're superimposing your
regret
on a fantasy and so i want to caution
you about that okay it's not real he
might be great he may be wonderful he's
not perfect okay the second thing is
have you sat down
any point over the last 30 years
and told your husband here's what i need
actually i did okay here we go we had
actually a long talk over the weekend
you did for the first time in 30 years
right
no no we've actually done it before okay
it's just kind of like um
okay you know and he's like well am i in
trouble no no no i just want to talk
but um i told him i said i want you to
make a list and you know things that you
think that
i could do to make our marriage better
um or whatever and
and i'll have a list and we'll sit down
talk
so he i gave him a pad of paper and he
wrote down three things and i'm like
that's it
but yeah that's all i can think of and
like okay be brutally honest he said no
that's that's it
and he wrote down communication intimacy
and he felt like he could help more i
was like well that's not really me
he said but well i know i need to help
more
um
the communication has you know kind of
always been an issue
um the intimacy deal is
it's hard for me because i have
fibromyalgia i've had some issues with i
think things in our past and things
early on on our marriage
um
i've been to the doctor because for
whatever reason this is gonna sound
truly bizarre
but there's been times when we've been
intimate and
i will suddenly have it like a
thunderclap headache
there's nothing strange about that
sex with your sex with your husband is
not safe for your body
so i mean i'm like and of course he's
just like wow i'm just that good huh
which is the classic thing for an idiot
to say in the middle right
i mean
he he was basically you know he was like
how can i help i'm sorry i'm sorry of
course of course of course of course and
of course i'm like you know grabbing my
head and just like bawling my eyes out
you know it'll last for a few minutes
and doctors they don't know anything
about it i'm like well what do i do and
i was like well here take this pill i'm
like
i take a lot of pills thanks a lot so
here's the thing here's the thing
just in the very limited things you're
telling me
sitting down and saying what are a
couple of things or what are all the
things that can make our marriage better
that's
that is a way to distance yourself
from you
and the whole crux of this book
is you looking in the mirror and saying
i need this
and you haven't done that
probably ever you may have said i want
this or it would really be nice if
but just just i'm reading between the
lines here
this guy hurt you before
yeah okay and it may have been multiple
times and for any number of reasons for
the sake of the marriage for the kids
for the appearance for whatever the
security and the financial safety
whatever the reasons yeah and i almost
left in a couple times there you go so
you've put this entity ahead of you for
a long time
and that's the way we're taught that's
the way sunday school taught people
that's the way
schools and parents are it's this thing
but if the people in this thing aren't
safe and aren't okay this thing doesn't
work right it's like focusing on the
building on the building and we don't
need steel let's just use styrofoam
because we're focusing on the building
it's like the building's gonna fall down
because the pillars aren't strong
and so instead of sitting down and
saying
hey what are the things write down
everything brutally honest that you can
make this marriage better
okay
say
what do you need from me
to give you a life that gives you peace
so that
you can give me what i need because for
35 years you have not
and that's going to come back to oh i do
this
and you know what he's kind of right on
one of the issues on probably all the
issues i don't he's probably right
i think it's fair
when he writes communication
it's not what he thinks
but i don't know how often you've sat
down and said
i still
can't breathe sometimes when i think
about what you did
yeah well and i i told them i said
i said you have to understand i said
there are certain things that
maybe you do that maybe are are triggers
and he said well that's not fair to
punish me for
things that happen and i i'm trying to
make him understand it's not you
it's just something i have to deal with
and i am seeing somebody right now right
so listen um this idea of well you can't
punish me for that is that's
oh that language pisses me off man
because it takes somebody else's really
honestly a good guy
hold on now you're going to defend him
and that's what you've done for 35 years
stop okay
i believe he's probably got some great
qualities awesome
you your body
is not safe with him
okay that doesn't mean he's gonna hurt
him there's yeah
right no i don't believe he won't hurt
me no exactly exactly
but right when it starts to get very
very real you roll off into trying to
defend him and protect him and it's fine
it's okay i just need to i get headaches
everyone
here's what i'm trying to tell you
you have to own what happened
period
and he's right
um punishment never solves anything it
just doesn't solve it's not gonna help
but right your pain and your hurt
isn't punishing him
yeah your pain and your hurt is
something you gotta heal from
it's classic self-centered
the whole world revolves around me when
somebody's healing from sexual trauma
and their partner's like oh are you
going to punish me by not having sex
with me
that's like me like stepping on a nail
and i gotta get my foot healed and my
wife goes oh you're gonna punish me by
not going for a run for me just cause
your foot has a nail in it yes well you
know i mean i know that i know that he
i'll put it this way we
in the past couple of years i can
probably count on
one hand the times that we've been
intimate and honestly
he has he told me at one point he said
no if we if we never have sex again it's
okay but of course it's not okay right
and you know i know he was trying to be
kind
and i know he he hates the things i have
to deal with he told me yesterday i
you know then another doctor and he said
i hate this i can't stand that you
had you have to deal with this but i'm
kind of like
i i deal with it it's just life so let
me ask you this
this is going to sound like a crazy
question
do you want to heal
and listen
hold on hold on before you answer that i
know the like of course i don't have
headaches anymore that's not that's not
the question headaches are the alarm
system
they're just letting you know that
you're not safe they're not okay and
again i'm not a doctor i'm just making
this up it could be completely
physiological but i'm just going off
based off what you just told me just now
okay
um
if you wanna heal
you're gonna have to
get with a therapist and deal with the
trauma from your past
because your body is still
responding in the present to things that
happen to you
your body has one mechanism and it's to
protect you from tigers or bears and
something happened in the past
probably multiple times as you as you
mentioned
that your brain has gps pinned him as a
bear
as a tiger he's not safe and until that
heals partly from you choosing
i'm gonna go deal with this
and that means you're gonna have to deal
with the consequences of what happened
because you may have to look at him and
said you did these things
and i've gotta heal from this
and then you're gonna have to say
now i'm gonna set these bricks down and
relearn what intimacy looks like with my
husband
right if that's the choice you make
or the choice might be that i'm out i'm
done with this yeah okay but all that to
say is
when i say are you ready to heal from
this
that's twofold are you ready to for real
probably for the first time
actually own this
and two are you willing to be vulnerable
and risk again moving forward
and both of those things have to be true
you cannot white-knuckle intimacy for
the rest of your marriage your bodies
continue to tell you i'm not safe i'm
not safe i'm not safe so are you
it feels here's what it feels like okay
and this is me just a picture of us
having nachos okay this isn't like i'm
not lecturing you
it feels like
you know
and it feels like he is a good guy he's
provided for us and he's done these
things
and you want to protect him and you want
to protect the image you want to protect
the thing you all have
and your body is saying we're not okay
we're not okay we're not okay am i right
or am i wrong yeah okay
and i don't i don't understand
completely why because
you know he
i i don't know i just feel like i'm just
so strange and i have talked to you
about it with um the person that i'm
seeing but it's almost kind of like
i'm being told
well that's that's in the past and you
just need to you know kind of deal with
it if a therapist tells you that get up
and walk out of their office
yeah
because it's not about you just bringing
up crap from the past to throw mud in
his face
your body's literally telling you not
safe not safe not safe not safe
and it will it's all through the book it
will you will continue your body will
continue to solve for these things
until you deal with them
right do you heal from them
i did happen to tell him because um
one thing is like um her
my daughter's boyfriend he's you know
he's financially disabled and i told my
husband you know we were in debt and i
told him i said you know that's one
thing i said i sat down with this
doesn't make me feel safe
you know when when i'm dealing with all
this and looking at what we have what we
don't have you know that's one thing i
did say i don't feel safe there you go
that's the language
whenever you take your clothes off
and you come towards me and i smell your
breath my body's my heart starts beating
faster and not in a good way
i gotta heal from that and i stiffen up
and i don't know why i mean it's like he
will come behind me and and hug me and i
can feel my body just that's right
and so be curious about that don't get
mad
don't get frustrated don't get angry get
curious why is my body trying to protect
me from my husband
what is it about i kind of know see
there you go you know you know
so becca if nothing else on this call
i'm giving you permission to go get well
and make no mistake
this journey will be
hell it'll be hard
because you know why your body stiffens
up
you know why
you gotta go deal with that
and that deal with that may be
confrontation it may be separation it
may be
emdr and trauma response and he's a part
of it and it may be you writing him
letters this is what happened this is
what you did to me and this is why my
body continues to respond and there's
going to be healing where your body
knows i wasn't safe then
because 30 years ago we were all
different people and 25 years ago he did
some things that hurt me that's not him
anymore
but i got to let my body know that at
one point this bear was going to eat me
and now this bear sleeps in the house
and that's the healing arc here
and that may mean that this pretty
beautiful
bone-white facade that you've created
around your life and your marriage and
your kids
it may be that it's gonna crumble on you
a little bit or you have to take some
pieces down are you gonna having to move
to a trailer for a while
all of that is in this i'm being
metaphorical by the way all that is
about safety
healing your body
because touch from your
husband just from your wife touch from
your romance
should be something that
gives your body
not the other way around
so be curious about that body response
but you don't have to be you already
know
let me say this
you're worth the healing
as hard as it's going to be
and
don't romanticize and lionize what your
daughter has cheer her on right
celebrate with her here's the deal
you're 54 so you're
you're a little over halfway done
because you're gonna live to be 100.
whenever you feel
jealous be curious about it like oh man
why am i getting frustrated when i see
him
oh i don't have these three things and
then we're going to loot back and have
that conversation again
this is right for counseling for you and
for your marriage um and at some point
this idea of communication this idea of
intimacy
you need to get there
but it's going to come down to those
conversations like you've begun in your
brave brave brave
i don't feel safe when
i don't feel safe when you touch me i
don't feel safe when we owe people money
i don't feel safe when i think you're
gonna quit all the time i don't feel
safe when you yell that has to end in
this home
and i want to learn how you can touch me
again but that means we're going to have
to go deal with what you did
and i'm going to have to forgive you for
that i'm going to set that down and then
i don't have to be vulnerable and risk
moving forward all these things right
and you got to get a professional to
walk with you because it's been a long
long long time
i believe you can do it i believe you
can do it and i'm proud of you for
taking first step and being brave
celebrate your daughter
and then you go get well